Olivia Munn and Aaron Rodgers may have  called it quits People magazine is  reporting the pair has split citing a  source the breakup would come after  engagement rumors in recent months monde  has been seen occasionally wearing a  sparkler on her engagement ring finger  and last May MUNs mother even gushed to  et about what a wedding would look like  big wedding they kind of wait for them  to get married we're not even engaged  but the actress has gone silent about  Rodgers on social media she has not  posted anything about the Packers player  since January  she also hit Vanity Fair's Oscars party  red carpet solo this year the couple was  together at the Oscars last year Beauty  spoke to them at the time it's my first  Oscars  it's about her she's presenting tonight  and it's trying to say either way you  check your dress weight he's been so  great make sure no one's on my train  [Music]